Professor Robert
Shiller: The fundamental
point that I want to make today
is that while economic theory
describes people as managing
their--maximizing their--own
utility and subject to
constraints,
most people have a lot of
trouble doing that,
particularly as regards to
investing in financial markets.
Most people are confused and
find it just very difficult,
so we have an industry of
people who help people with
their investments and we,
moreover, have a whole array of
regulations regulating the
industry of people who help
others with their investments.
The problem is that most people
are not that good at dealing in
financial markets.
They're mysterious,
they're difficult,
and, moreover,
there's a tendency of
psychological biases that cause
people to get into mistakes.
We talked about
overconfidence--that most people
think they're smarter than
others--and it seems like people
can easily get overconfident
about their ability to beat the
market.
What naturally happens,
if not regulated,
is that there will be others
who will victimize and exploit
these people.
The classic story is some kind
of stockbroker who promises to
make great wealth for you by
trading your portfolio and,
in fact, doesn't really know
anything;
the guy is just a showman who
is just pretending.
There was a 1940s book called,
Where Are The Customers
Yachts?, which was a
best-selling book.
The title refers to the fact
that stockbrokers give the
impression that I deal with a
very wealthy successful crowd of
people and you are now one of
the chosen people that I'm
managing for.
Some stockbrokers will pretend
to be very wealthy--create the
appearance of that--like they're
associated with the rich people
and it draws people in.
But in fact,
the customers often don't do
very well because the
stockbroker may churn their
portfolio,
keep coming up with new trades,
and the broker is making money
from commissions.
That's the kind of problem that
arises.
As a result,
a lot of people recognize the
importance of giving help to
people, so that's what we're
talking about.
I want to talk mostly about
portfolio managers,
but I'll first talk about
financial advisors and also
financial planners and then I'll
move to fiduciaries or
institutional investors.
We do not live in a world where
people freely do business as
they would like.
The financial world is
especially heavily-regulated.
The first thing is financial
advisor;
again, most people don't know
about these markets and they
need someone to give them
advice, so people set themselves
up as financial advisors.
In most countries,
these are heavily regulated by
the government.
In the United States-- Now,
what is a financial advisor?
I should define that for you.
It's someone who gives advice
about investments for some kind
of fee or commission.
It excludes lawyers,
bankers, insurance salesmen,
reporters from newspapers,
professors.
Even though these people may
all give financial advice,
it's not considered as part of
law to be central to what they
do,
so they are excluded from the
definition of financial advisor.
It also excludes broker-dealers.
If someone presents himself or
herself just as a broker--that's
someone you can call up and say,
I want to buy a hundred shares
of GM or whatever and the person
does the deal--does the trade
for you.
That is also not a financial
advisor, even if that person
occasionally dispenses advice.
It's only incidental to the
business.
Financial advisors includes
people who present themselves as
offering advice to individuals
and also includes analysts.
These are regulated and there's
something called the National
Securities Markets Improvement
Act of 1996 that says that all
financial advisors with less
then twenty-five million under
management must register with
their state regulator and if
it's greater than thirty
million,
they must register with the SEC
in Washington--Securities and
Exchange Commission.
If it's between,
they can choose either one.
They're all regulated and the
government wants to be sure that
financial advisors are--know
what good practice is and so
that means they have to take an
exam.
The exam is administered by
what's called FINRA,
that is Financial Institutions
Regulatory Authority--formerly
called NASD.
See how this is getting
complicated?
NASD is National Association of
Securities Dealers and they
started the NASDAQ stock market
index, which you hear about all
the time.
NASDAQ is NASD Automated
Quotation System.
NASD merged with the New York
Stock Exchange Regulatory
Authority last year,
so they've been renamed as
FINRA.
These are all these
institutional details that I
want you to know because
it--it's boring,
maybe, but I think it's what's
true;
it's what's happening;
this is what drives so much
that happens.
FINRA says that if you want to
become a financial advisor,
you have to pass a Series--they
call it Series 65 or 66 exam and
then you are eligible,
according to FINRA.
FINRA is an example of an SRO,
a self-regulatory organization.
The government in the United
States doesn't want to be making
all the rules,
so they allow industry groups
to form their own self-policing
organizations.
So, FINRA is the organization
for financial advisors and that
is an SRO and the SEC accepts
their licensing.
That's what you have to do to
become a financial advisor.
You have to take these exams,
join FINRA, then you go to the
SEC, and then you register as a
financial advisor.
The exams would warn you about
all kinds of bad practices
that--for example,
about churning a portfolio.
I just mentioned that,
but I'll repeat it;
that's when you call the guy up
everyday and you say,
I just got a hot new idea for
you.
Of course, yesterday you bought
Microsoft--sell that,
move to this.
They just keep calling you up
and that's--it's a way to get
de-licensed if you are caught
doing that because it can't
work.
If you trade everyday there's
no--it's virtually impossible to
make money because the
commissions will eat you alive.
You know these guys who are
churning are fakes because they
can't be getting a new idea
everyday, so that's the kind of
thing.
Now, financial planners are a
little different.
The designation of financial
planner is not regulated
directly, but we do have a
self-regulatory association that
manages them.
We have the Financial Planning
Association--that's their
website, FPA.org--and they
license--they provide their own
designation.
This is how it works in the
U.S., particularly;
they will certify someone as a
certified financial planner and
FPA will require that every
financial planner first become a
financial advisor.
So, that's--this is a big
organization.
Incidentally,
if anyone ever asks you,
I need investment advice,
where do I get it?
It might be a good idea to
direct them to that website
because they'll help you get a
financial planner,
which is more than a broker;
they're supposed to actually be
planning for your life.
That's the essential economic
problem that we face.
Stockbrokers will often--this
comes back to what Henry Paulson
said in his proposal for
reorganization of our financial
markets.
He thought--and I think this
may reflect some essential
wisdom--that we should have
objectives-based regulation.
Each organization should be
focused on an objective.
I think the objective of the
organization affects what you
do.
If you are a stockbroker and if
you present yourself as someone
who will buy and sell stocks for
you,
you're probably not going to
get into financial planning with
your clients.
If it's on your title,
if you write this after your
name--John Doe,
CFP--then it says planner in
your title.
I think that affects what you
do and it tells--what financial
planners do is they say,
let's sit down and think about
your life goals.
Do you expect to have children?
Are you going to send them to
college?
This kind of thought,
which is very important.
There's another one
called--this is for financial
advisors, NAPFA.org,
National Association of
Personal Financial Advisors.
If someone asks you,
where should I go for advice?
This is another good website to
go to because--what I like about
NAPFA.org is that they have all
of their advisors sign a
statement that they will be
fee-only advisors and they will
never steer someone toward an
investment that provides a
kickback to them.
That's a problem--that often a
financial advisor will be really
trying to make money selling you
things that provide money;
they're not unbiased.
But NAPFA--it's part of their
code of ethics that they're
completely separate from any
organization.
They're pure financial advisors
and they don't make money from
commissions;
it's only from the hourly fee.
What else?
So, that's basically what I was
going to say about financial
advisors;
it's a big industry and it's
important.
Actually, in my new book--I
have no--I should say,
I have no connection to this
industry whatsoever,
but I actually was saying that
I think as a national policy we
should subsidize this industry.
I think people need more
financial advice.
Most people are just not with
it enough;
they're not getting the basic
wisdom that--I think if we need
more of this,
we should subsidize it.
I was just in Mexico over the
weekend and I had the
opportunity to meet the
President of Mexico,
which was exciting,
and I also heard him say that
he thinks Mexico needs more
development of financial
culture.
This seems to be a thing that
not enough Mexicans are really
used to dealing
with--sophisticated financial
institutions--and so that's
where we have to go with Mexico.
I was saying,
well it's just the same in
every country;
I think there's a problem.
The other thing--I won't say
more about financial advisors,
but let's move now to the other
way that happens is that people
will turn over their--actually,
I want to come back to trusts
later.
Let me--the other--the really
big industry that manages
peoples' financial problems for
them are institutional
investors.
These are groups
that--organizations--that pool
money from many people and
invest a portfolio for them.
I want to start by emphasizing
how important they are.
I want to just present you with
the balance sheet for households
and non-profits and just get
some idea of how important
institutional investors are.
They're more important than
these financial advisors because
most of people's wealth is
really managed by institutions.
You don't have to ask any
questions they just--you don't
have to do anything;
it's all done for you.
I wanted to show the balance
sheet of households and
non-profits and that's table
B100 of the Flow of Funds
Account;
this is for the United States,
but I think it would be similar
in other countries.
We have assets on one side and
we have liabilities on the
other, so we'll have assets and
then we'll have liabilities.
You might wonder,
why do we put households and
non-profits together?
It's really because there are
three types of persons that own
things.
There are individuals or
natural persons;
there are non-profit
organizations,
which are like individuals
because nobody owns them--they
own themselves.
They're like people in contrast
to corporations that are owned
by individuals.
Then, we also have the
government, is the third.
This is the non-government
balance sheet,
so it's just about everything
in this country.
I just wanted to review--this
is from the Federal Reserve and
these are estimates,
of course, and subject to
error;
this is for 2007,
fourth quarter,
which is the latest data.
Assets are things that people
own and liabilities are things
that people owe and your net
worth is your assets minus your
liabilities.
Let's start with assets.
The biggest asset that people
own in the United States--that
households own is--and
non-profits--this is almost
entirely households though;
non-profits are small compared
to households.
Real estate is the biggest
thing and that is 22,438 billion
dollars or 22 trillion dollars;
people own this directly--it's
their house.
The second most--the second
biggest thing is pension funds
and that is 12 billion--I mean
it's 12 trillion dollars--12,779
billion;
that comes right after real
estate.
Then we have equity in
non-corporate business and that
is 7,389--sorry,
it's 7,892--it's almost 8
billion.
What is non-corporate business?
It's businesses run by
individuals, so it's like the
low--if a family runs a little
grocery store,
then their ownership of that is
represented here as
non-corporate business.
Or, if you're a barber and
you've got your little
barbershop.
It all adds up;
they valued all of these
businesses and they valued them
up totally as worth 8 trillion
dollars.
Then we have corporate
equities--that's stock--and that
is 5,447 billion or about 5
trillion dollars.
That's stocks owned directly by
households.
Then we have mutual funds.
Mutual funds are institutional
investors that invest in stocks
or bonds, but usually it's
mostly stocks--5.082 trillion.
It's almost as big as corporate
equities held directly.
Then there's consumer
durables--that means your car,
your furniture;
that's 4,035 billion.
Bonds--2,730 billion--not so
much, not as big.
Insurance--I have everything
ranked by size,
so we're going down the scale.
Insurance is--this is life
insurance--1,205.
Then--I'm running out of room
at the bottom--there are some
other minor categories,
but the total is--I would
normally put it at the bottom,
but I am running out of room at
the bottom.
The total assets total is
72,093 billion,
so it's 72 trillion dollars.
Liabilities of households are
mortgages--home mortgages--and
that's 10,509.
Consumer credit--credit
cards--installment credit of
various types--2,551.
Loans and other--1,315 billion.
The total liabilities is 14,315
billion.
So, people own 72 trillion;
they owe 14 trillion;
the difference is net
worth--57,718 billion.
So, that's about $192,000 per
person in the United States.
It's unequally held;
this is just consolidating
everybody.
It's unequally held because
rich people own more of this
than poor people.
The average family of four has
about $800,000.
I'm just multiplying $192,000
by 4.
So, we have a lot of wealth.
The point here is,
what form is it in?
Well, real estate is very
unmanaged;
people own their own homes and
there's not much institutional
involvement except through the
mortgage.
Note that they owe about
half--they only own about half
of their home.
The average person owes on the
mortgage almost half the value
of their home.
If you took net worth in real
estate, it would be only like 12
trillion dollars;
assets minus real estate
liability.
By that account,
the biggest asset that people
have is apparently their pension
fund;
that's huge and that is
institutional investors.
The thing I wanted to make--the
point I wanted to make about
this is that institutional
investors dominate just about
everything.
I mean, you've got real estate
and non-corporate business,
which are not easily managed by
institutional investors.
Beyond that,
it's mostly institutional
mutual funds and insurance.
We live in a country where
things are managed by
professional investors.
Let's talk about--what is a
mutual fund?
A mutual fund refers to a
structure of an investment
company.
They're much more important
than hedge funds.
Hedge funds are--we talked
about those before--are designed
for a small group of wealthy
investors.
Mutual funds are for the
general public and the reason
they're called mutual is that
the fund is owned by the
investors in it.
The first mutual fund was
called MIT--no connection with
Massachusetts Institute of
Technology.
This was the Massachusetts
Investors Trust in the 1920s.
At that time,
there were a lot of investor
funds that were
not--relatively--unregulated and
they were offering investments
to people that were oversold,
often.
Often there were classes of
shareholders.
There was a class of prime
shareholders who got the profits
from the enterprise and then
there was a class of other
shareholders who were the hoi
polloi.
After 1929,
many of the investment funds
crashed and burned and people
got very upset.
They were very upset,
particularly,
that the investment fund was
really being run for the profit
and benefit of the guys who
started the fund,
not all the people who were in
there.
After 1929, there was some
looking around as how should
investment funds really be
organized.
Then attention became focused
on MIT because it was an honest
fund and they thought this
should be the model for our
investment fund industry.
What Massachusetts Investment
Trust did is they said,
everybody is equal and we're
completely open about what we
do.
We publish our portfolio and
most investment funds were
secret.
They were saying,
well we're going to beat the
market;
we're not going to publish what
we're doing.
The MIT published its portfolio
and it had only one class of
investors.
In fact, the fund was owned by
the investors;
it's a mutual fund,
so if you put money in,
you join the crowd.
We invest for you and if you
want to take your money out,
we'll share your proportion of
the whole portfolio.
That was the concept,
so the concept became very
widely respected and the whole
industry grew.
The Investment Act of
1940--Investment Company Act of
1940--it doesn't actually define
mutual funds,
but it defines structures that
are used by mutual funds.
After the Investment Company
Act, starting in the 1950s,
mutual funds began to grow and
grow.
They are regulated in such a
way that the--as I said,
everyone is equal in the fund;
everyone benefits from the
portfolio in an equal way.
The rule is that if--you don't
buy and sell shares in the
mutual fund.
The fund owns shares;
you're putting money into the
fund and if you want to get
money out of the fund,
you call them up or maybe you
can do it on the web.
You say--you place an order to
withdraw money from the fund.
What they will do when you
withdraw money is they wait
until four p.m.
on the day of your order and
then they calculate what your
share of the fund would be based
on--four p.m.
is when the stock markets close.
So, at four p.m.
you would get out at those
prices and that was considered a
fair and honest thing to do.
They don't charge high
management fees;
there are rules about that.
So, they have their own SRO
called ICI, Investment Company
Institute.
That was created,
I believe, in the 1940s.
This has become the structure
for the way most people--well,
half the people--most small
investors do not own corporate
equity directly;
they own mutual funds.
There have been some scandals
about mutual funds that emerged
in the last decade or so.
There's something called late
trading.
What was happening was,
sometimes these mutual funds
didn't enforce the rules well
enough.
You would tell your broker,
I'd like to withdraw money from
the mutual fund.
The broker would then sometimes
call after four p.m.
and say, my client really asked
me to sell this at ten a.m.
this morning.
I know it's five p.m.,
but trust me,
I'd like to get out.
Mutual funds would let this
happen.
Then it turned out to be
abusive.
Why is that abusive?
If you're a mutual fund and you
get this call from a broker
saying, trust me my client asked
me to get out at ten a.m.;
I know it's five.
Can we get out?
Well, that turns out to be a
bad practice because what ended
up happening was people abused
that.
They would wait until five or
six p.m.
and they would observe what
seems to be happening in the
markets.
If it's going up,
then they would say,
we want to put money into the
mutual fund.
If it's going down,
they would say,
we're trying to take money out
of the mutual fund.
You see how that hurts the
other mutual fund investors
because you do it strategically.
You do--if you know the market
is up, you're trading on stale
prices--on old prices.
So, obviously you could make
money doing that and this got a
lot of attention in the
newspaper--the late trading.
There was another variation on
that called market timing,
but it's basically the same
thing--where mutual funds were
not enforcing the rules properly
and so some people were trading
at four p.m.
prices, effectively after it.
They've cleaned up this act,
so I think that mutual funds
are our most trusted way of
investing in the stock market
and most people won't invest in
individual stocks anymore;
they just go through mutual
funds.
There is another kind of thing
that has developed more recently
and it's called an Exchange
Traded Fund or an ETF.
These were created first--these
are relatively new.
These were created first at the
American Stock Exchange in 1993
and they're different from a
mutual fund.
I didn't show them separately
on this;
they're much smaller than
mutual funds,
but I believe they're less than
a trillion dollars.
They must be in one of these
other categories up there.
Exchange Traded Funds are
different than a mutual fund in
that they are traded on a stock
exchange.
The first Exchange Traded Fund
was a company called the
SPDR--that's Standard and Poor's
Depository Receipt.
But now, there is a
proliferation of Exchange Traded
Funds.
What is an Exchange Traded Fund?
Exchanged Traded Fund is
epitomized by the--this is the
S&P 500--it's a portfolio
that is managed according to
rules;
it's not judgmental.
You cannot call up the Exchange
Traded Fund and say,
I want my money back.
It's different from a mutual
fund.
If you get--you would buy or
sell an Exchange Traded Fund on
the stock exchange.
The fund is traded--the
Exchange Traded Fund holds a
portfolio, like the SPDR holds a
portfolio equivalent to the
S&P 500 and they pay out
dividends on that.
But in the meantime,
you can buy or sell shares in
the fund on the stock exchange.
They also have what are called
creation units,
which are in large
denominations,
like millions of dollars.
Institutional investors can
either create or redeem shares
in the ETFs, but you as an
individual cannot.
If the creation unit is one
million dollars,
then an institutional investor
who is an authorized participant
and has signed the right papers
can go to the AMEX and say,
I want to create ten million
dollars of new SPDRs.
Then, the AMEX will--that's ten
creation units.
I forget what a SPDRs creation
unit is, but let's say it's a
million dollars.
Then the AMEX would say,
alright, you have to give us
the stocks in the S&P 500 in
the proportion that they are in
the S&P 500,
equal in value to ten million
dollars.
That becomes one creation unit
and then they'll give the
institutional investors the
shares to sell.
Conversely, the institutional
investor can go to the AMEX and
say, I want to go the other way.
I've got 10,000 shares of these
ETFs;
I want the stocks back.
So, the institutional investor
can present the shares to the
AMEX and the AMEX will then give
them the shares in the S&P
500.
That enforces the price of the
ETF equal to the price of the
underlying stocks.
ETFs were designed so that the
price of the ETF tracks the
price of the underlying stocks.
In contrast,
those things called Closed End
Funds, which are similar,
but they don't have the
creation units.
Closed End Funds--the price of
the fund on the stock market
tends to go through either a
premium or a discount depending
on the market,
but ETFs tend to track well.
That is, the price of the ETF
tends to correspond to the price
of the underlying stocks;
whereas, closed end mutual
funds--closed end funds track
poorly.
So, ETFs are the new things
that have developed.
I said I would talk about
personal trusts.
This is something that is of
less--somewhat less--importance,
but it's about a trillion
dollars in our modern economy.
What is a trust?
It's another form of
institutional investing.
A trust is a--it's often a
department of a bank that
manages money on behalf of an
individual or family.
For example,
suppose your parents are
concerned about you and they
don't trust you--they trust the
banker, not you--and there's a
family fortune.
Maybe it doesn't have to be
that big, but let's say it's a
million dollars.
They could give it to you,
but they might not.
I don't know what your parents
are doing;
they're doing this behind your
back and maybe not telling you
in great detail.
Of particular importance,
as an example,
is something called a
spendthrift trust.
What is a spendthrift?
It's someone who can't save
money and squanders it.
Your parents can go to a bank
and set up a spendthrift trust
on your behalf and the
spendthrift trust will then pay
you an income for life.
Or, they could even go beyond
your life;
they could go to your children
or whatever.
That prevents you from
squandering the money--from
going to the casino and gambling
it away if your parents don't
trust you.
You see the idea?
The bank then will manage it
for the rest of your life and
your parents will die and you
will outlive them,
but that money will be stuck in
that trust and you can't get it
out because they set it up and
it's there.
The manager of the trust is a
fiduciary who is,
by contract,
is supposed to be managing in
the interest of the child--the
spendthrift child.
Of course, everyone--all these
people will be dead before you
are.
Your parents will die;
the person they talked to at
the bank setting up the trust
will die, but when you're ninety
years old there will be someone
at that bank--some person much
younger than you--who was
appointed in succession to
manage your trust and will
continue to pay you that income
out of your trust.
Now, if there's another reason
why your parents might be doing
this, which--you might be angry
with your parents if they did
this,
but they might do it for
another reason.
That is, you could get married
and get a divorce and they're
worried about this really awful
person you married taking half
of the family money when you get
divorced.
They lock it up in a
spendthrift trust and then after
the divorce the trustee will
say,
no way, I'm bound to pay this
person--not the wife or
husband--the amount of money for
life.
It apparently works.
So, that's another reason why
families will do this because
they don't want to give the
money to the awful person you
married.
In Common Law countries,
trusts are--that's the U.S.
and the UK--trusts are
well-defined in law and a
trustee has well-defined rights.
If you are--and it doesn't have
to be a bank;
you could have a friend of
yours become a trustee.
In Common Law countries,
there's a nice segregation of
the assets in the trust and the
assets of the trustee.
Suppose you ask your
brother-in-law to serve as a
trustee for your children and
then your brother-in-law gets
into some bad financial
situation and goes bankrupt;
courts will not be allowed to
take the Trust that the
brother-in-law is managing for
your children.
This wasn't so clear in Civil
Law countries,
such as in Europe.
The typical trust in Europe has
been that you would go to a bank
and the bank would manage the
trust for you.
If the bank went under,
you might lose the money.
Maybe they're more trusting of
their banks in Europe,
but I think this is also
changing.
The law is always changing.
Now, I want to come to pension
funds, which are the most
important kind of institution.
You can see up there,
that's the twelve trillion
dollars.
It doesn't include--this
pension fund here does not
include Social Security,
which is of comparable
magnitude.
The government runs its own
pension fund,
in effect, called the Social
Security System and that's not
shown here.
Pension funds are private funds
managing a portfolio of assets.
The Social Security System does
not manage a substantial
portfolio of assets.
The Social Security System,
which is a--it's not on here,
I'm just mentioning it as an
aside--was set up by U.S.
Congress in 1935 to provide for
the elderly and also for
disabled and orphaned children.
But, the main Social Security
provides for the elderly.
It does so without
investing--there is something
called the Social Security Trust
Fund managed by the government,
which invests in assets to help
the government pay out on social
security.
However, the Social Security
Trust Fund is only,
last time I heard about it,
one trillion dollars
[Correction: the Social Security
Old Age and Survivors Insurance
Trust Fund assets rose from 1.07
trillion dollars in 2001 to 2.02
trillion dollars in 2007.].
So, the government is not
investing much compared to these
pension funds;
pension funds are much bigger.
These are agencies--private
agencies--that invest on behalf
of people for their retirement
and they are a very important
element of our economy.
They help us solve the
essential problem that everyone
goes through their life
cycle--you're young;
you're healthy for a while;
you're working.
Then, your health starts to
deteriorate and then you have
years or decades when you are
either not inclined to work or
cannot work and this happens
with such regularity that it
requires some kind of
professional management;
that's what pension funds do.
I want to talk about these in
some more detail.
It wasn't until the nineteenth
century that we had them,
which is kind of surprising
because it's such an important
problem.
Even in the nineteenth century
they were few and rare.
The first U.S.--I think they go
back earlier in the U.K.
and in places in Europe,
but in the United States the
first corporate pension fund was
American Express in 1875.
American Express,
then, was not a credit card
company;
it was a shipping company or
transportation company.
This first pension fund was for
the employees of American
Express and the original terms
were,
you had to work there for
twenty years and past the age of
sixty and you had also to be
disabled.
If you satisfied those--if you
were over sixty,
you had worked at American
Express for twenty years,
and also were disabled--you
would get 50% of the average pay
for the last ten years you
worked there.
This is the earliest model in
the U.S.
and that gradually became
copied by more companies.
It became more and more
important as we moved into the
twentieth century because life
expectancy was going up.
There were relatively few
people with--the life expectancy
at 1900 was something like
forty-five years;
I don't have the exact number.
So, sixty was a milestone that
a lot of people didn't reach.
Of course, many did as well,
so it's not--this was important
even then.
The original pension funds
tended to be done for the
benefit of the employer in the
sense that,
like the American Express,
you had to work there for all
of twenty years in order to get
anything;
it was all or nothing.
If you worked there for
nineteen years,
then too bad;
you got nothing.
It didn't seem well-designed,
but it was designed to keep
people there;
they didn't want people leaving.
So, once you signed on to
American Express,
you were kind of stuck there
because you didn't want to get
out;
you'd lose your pension.
It wasn't very big--or big
institution.
In Carnegie Steel--pension plan
was 1901--Andrew Carnegie--which
was a milestone because it
started to establish the
principle on a--this was the
first big company to establish a
pension fund.
It grew through the first few
decades of the nineteenth
century and by 1929 there were
many pension funds.
They started doing union
pension funds.
There were the cigar
makers--that was a
union--granite cutters and cigar
makers--1905.
Locomotive engineers--that was
1912--but many of these funds
failed in 1929 and they were
offered by companies for their
employees or unions for their
members.
When companies offered pensions
for their employees,
that was a risky thing because
companies go bankrupt;
it happens all the time.
If they go bankrupt,
how are they going to pay the
pension plan?
Well, that was tough luck for
the employees.
That was a less enlightened
time.
They didn't--the point was that
they rarely funded the pension
funds.
In the early decades of the
twentieth century,
Carnegie Steel just--I don't
know about Carnegie,
but generally,
they just promised to pay.
They just said,
we will pay you when you
retire;
out of what, you might ask.
Well, that wasn't explained,
but it had to be out of
profits.
What if they weren't making any
profits?
Well, people didn't seem to
anticipate this.
After 1929, these pension funds
became discredited because so
many of them failed.
That led to an idea that we had
to do something different.
The big milestone in pension
history is the General Motors
Pension Fund,
GM Pension,
which was created in 1950 and
it was promoted by GM Chairman,
Charles Wilson.
I visited them recently;
they're in that building right
across the street from the Plaza
Hotel at the corner of Central
Park;
they're a very big organization
now.
The thing that GM Pension Fund
did, it invested--it funded--so,
they started investing money on
behalf of the pensioners so that
if GM were ever to go bankrupt,
there would still be money in
the fund.
Not GM Stock--this was the most
amazing thing--General Motors
was investing money for its
pension fund and of all things
it wasn't buying GM stock.
Some people thought,
why wouldn't they buy their own
stock?
That would push the price up.
Of course, it's not enlightened
to buy their own stock
because--that would be stupid to
invest the pension fund in your
own stock because the stock
would become worthless in the
same circumstance that you would
be unable to make good on the
pension,
so it wouldn't do any good.
It just seems obvious that
companies should fund their
pension funds and should invest
in something other than their
own stock.
That may seem obvious,
but it took until 1950.
One thing that strikes me about
financial history is that it
seems like we go for such a long
time doing things that are
obviously not right and,
as long as there's no crisis,
nobody pays attention to it.
Then, we have this huge crisis,
like the 1929 stock market
crash, and then it's only after
the crisis that anyone thinks
about it.
I don't know what was happening
for the first thirty years of
the twentieth century;
they had all these pension
funds, but the whole idea seemed
to be faulty.
Why would you think that your
company can support you in your
old age?
That's decades in the future.
The chance that your company
would go under has to be
substantial, but people don't
seem to see these risks and they
don't think about them until
there's a big crisis.
That's why I think that we are
at an opportune time right now
with another financial crisis;
it's a time when people might
be willing to think about how to
do things differently.
The next big crisis in pension
fund history was the Studebaker
default in 1963.
Have you ever heard of
Studebaker?
None of you have heard of them?
They made cars.
They were one of the big--I
don't know how many carmakers in
the 50s and 60s.
You probably still see these on
the road, but they're getting
quite rare because that was
forty-five years ago.
They were big for a while.
Anyway, the company went
bankrupt in 1963 and now they
claimed to have funded a pension
plan.
They were learning from GM and
they were investing a pension
plan for their employees in
assets that should have survived
a bankruptcy;
so they thought.
After the bankruptcy,
they found out that they had
underfunded the pension plan.
That means that they didn't put
enough money in to pay what they
promised to pay,
so while they had it they just
didn't put enough in.
Then people started getting
angry obviously;
people that worked their lives
at Studebaker--they were told
that they had a funded pension
fund.
When they--later they found
that they got nothing or at
least very much reduced.
People started looking at the
union, United Auto Workers.
Isn't the United Auto Workers
supposed to stand up for the
rights of the employees and
shouldn't they be looking at the
pension fund and demanding that
Studebaker fund it adequately?
Well, they were not--they were
asleep at the switch.
Some people accuse the UAW of
complicity with Studebaker--that
basically the UAW was not paying
attention to the distant future
because they didn't think that
their members really cared.
UAW wanted, when they had
negotiations with Studebaker,
they wanted big pay increases
now;
they didn't care about funding
the pension fund.
Why didn't they care?
Well, because the workers at
Studebaker didn't know or
understand this and so the
workers were not attuned to
this.
So, the union thrives on
getting something that looks
valuable to the employees,
but the employees were being
deceived.
Both Studebaker and the union
were in it together against the
employees, in a sense;
so, this created a lot of anger
about failures of pension funds.
I'm talking about financial
crises of years past.
We're going through a subprime
crisis right now and this is
just one of a series.
Every time we have a financial
crisis we make fixes.
In reaction to the
Studebaker--it took ten years,
but the Studebaker default set
in force a dialogue about how
pensions should be managed.
That led to ERISA
1974--actually eleven years
later.
ERISA stands for Employment
Retirement Income Security Act
and it then required funding--it
required adequate funding.
Studebaker had a funded pension
plan, but it was underfunded,
so that's what ERISA created.
They also created the Pension
Benefits Guarantee Corporation,
the PBGC.
This is a government--well,
it's a government-sponsored
enterprise that insures--the
Pension Benefit Guarantee Corp.
It's like the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation,
which guarantees your bank
deposit;
it guarantees your pension plan.
So, the PBGC then receives dues
from pension plans and the
pension plans then,
if they were to fail,
would get--the pensioners would
get a payment from the PBGC.
The PBGC is supposed to monitor
the funds of pension plans--make
sure that they're adequately
funded.
Then if they are not adequately
funded, then they would make up
the difference.
Now, ultimately the PBGC has a
portfolio of assets,
which it accumulates from the
fees paid to it by the pension
funds.
That portfolio of assets might
not be adequate in a huge
crisis, so Congress might have
to step in to support the PBGC;
otherwise, the PBGC is not
taking taxpayers' money.
Recently, the PBGC has come
under some attack because after
the stock market--it's very hard
to know whether a pension fund
is adequately funded or not
because it all depends on
assumptions about asset prices.
During the run up of stock
market in the 1990s,
firms started cutting back on
the amount they contributed to
their retirement funds because
the stock market had made their
plans look very rich.
There are people like me
claiming that it was a bubble,
so the prices were not going to
stay at this level,
but it's kind of hard to prove
that point.
So, companies in the late
90s were not--they were
putting their money in risky
stocks and saying they were
adequately-funded when there
were people like me who were
doubting that.
The PBGC, being a government
organization,
didn't protest--after the stock
market came down after 2000,
it put the PBGC in jeopardy.
Fortunately,
the market went back up again
and kind of bailed them out.
The ERISA Act also embodied
something called the Prudent
Person Rule.
Actually, in 1974 they called
it the Prudent Man Rule--that
was because '74 was just before
we tried to use non-sexist
language.
So, the Prudent Man Rule is now
the Prudent Person Rule,
but I'll read what the ERISA
said.
The Act said,
"Investments must be made with
the care, skill,
prudence, and diligence under
the circumstances then
prevailing that a prudent man,
acting in a like capacity and
familiar with such matters,
would use in the conduct of an
enterprise of a like character
and with like aims."
That's lawyer-ese,
but basically what they're
saying--the fundamental problem
that even if you get beyond the
deliberate underfunding of a
pension plan,
you still get the possibility
that the pension managers will
do something wild like put
everything in the stock market
or they could be leveraged
investments in the stock market.
They could say,
we're funded enough because
with this hugely-leveraged
portfolio we should have enough
money, but that wouldn't be
prudent.
If the government is
guaranteeing pension plans as
they started doing with the
PBGC,
then they've got to prevent
that because they can't just let
companies just do wild
investments.
This put the government in a
funny circumstance because it
was starting to tell these funds
that they had to be doing
sensible investing.
What is sensible investing?
It actually was a difficult
thing to define.
Look at Yale University.
Back in--when David Swensen
came to Yale,
most universities put their
money in sensible,
safe, government bonds;
stocks were considered risky.
But Swensen said,
no let's not do that;
let's put into these strange,
alternative investments and
after the fact he turns out to
be right.
Was he not prudent?
Do you want to tell investment
companies that they shouldn't do
that?
It's a difficult question and
the question is:
how far should a pension plan
go in taking on risky
investments?
The law created this strange
Prudent Person Rule,
which says that an investment
company should do whatever a
prudent person would do;
it created an unfortunate
environment for pension fund
management.
Basically, they're telling
pension fund managers,
don't use your own judgment;
do what somebody else would do
and you manage the portfolio.
I mean, that's law;
you've got to do this.
It's in the law as a manager,
so it's a slippery business to
be in.
I have on the--I don't expect
you to go to read this because
it should be in the library,
but O'Barr &
Conley [Willam M.
O'Barr and John M.
Conley, Fortune and Folly:
The Wealth and Power of
Institutional Investing,
Homewood Illinois:
Business One Irwin,
1992]
wondered how pension funds deal
with this strange situation that
they're put in.
This is O'Barr &
Conley, who wrote a book.
One of these is an
anthropologist,
so we're getting a little bit
of insight--I mentioned,
I like to take insights from
all the different social
sciences.
Anthropologists like to go into
some primitive village somewhere
in the world and interview
people who live in a very
different culture and try to
learn about them.
What an anthropologist does is
goes into some village and
doesn't disturb their--tries not
to disturb their culture;
doesn't start explaining
things, just listens and tries
to understand how they think;
has to learn their language and
listen to their--presumably to
get insights about human
behavior from the experience of
immersing oneself in some other
culture.
These people went to interview
pension fund managers with the
same techniques that
anthropologists use in primitive
villages and they concluded that
pension funds are--they were
rather critical of pension
funds.
The pension funds are living in
this strange world created by
ERISA, which requires that they
behave as somebody else would.
It kind of separates them from
any real sense of their mission;
they're regulated so heavily.
So, what O'Barr &
Conley found is that--they
engaged people in discussion;
they listed to what managers of
pension funds would say on their
own without suggesting the topic
of conversation.
What they found was that
managers were very much aware of
the Prudent Person Rule and that
they were always looking to
shift blame--possible blame.
They were also thinking of some
lawsuit that they could
eventually be embroiled in and
they were always saying,
well this is what a prudent
person would do.
They talked a lot about the law
and relatively little about
economics or the objectives that
they're supposed to have about
how do we get to the management
of--how do we manage this
portfolio to provide for the
benefits to our employees in the
future.
It's interesting that as
anthropologists,
they took note of what
anthropologists have noted in
many primitive societies.
If you let people living in
some isolated culture talk,
they tend to come up eventually
with a creation myth.
This is a term that
anthropologists use;
every primitive society--you
can ask them,
where did it all start?
They will generally have a
story about the creation of
their little village or their
people,
which involves some great man
or god that founded everything.
There's some story about this
person and a sense that we are
the chosen people--that we're
the--we have some values or--and
it's built around a story of
some great man or woman,
I suppose.
What they said was,
that's one of the things they
heard most commonly--the
creation myth.
So, they would say,
our pension fund was started by
so and so forty years ago;
this person had great insights
and we're living in this
tradition ever since.
Anyway, ERISA came in at more
or less the end of era.
There are really two kinds of
pension plans;
there is defined benefit and
defined contribution.
There's a fundamental
difference.
A defined benefit pension plan
tells you that the pension will
pay you a certain amount.
For example,
I mentioned the very first U.S.
pension fund--American Express.
It promised to pay you 50% of
your average pay for the last
ten years that you were
employed.
You were told this when you
started the job that this was
your plan, so that defined the
benefit you would get.
Until 1974, virtually all
pension plans were defined
benefit.
There were some exceptions,
but it was the overwhelming
norm.
Labor unions liked defined
benefit;
it sounded right to them,
but the contrary kind is called
defined contribution.
In a defined contribution plan,
the pension plan does not
promise you anything about what
your retirement income will be.
They merely say that we are
going to contribute a fraction
of your salary to a portfolio
that will be managed to provide
you income when you retire.
The amount you get will be
determined by the portfolio and
not by any arbitrary rule.
There's nothing like 50% of the
last ten years of your income.
The defined contribution plans
got their biggest impetus in
1981.
So that's what,
seven years after ERISA with
the advent of what was called
401(k) plans.
401(k) is a paragraph in the
Internal Revenue Service
Code--that's the tax--that's the
IRS, the agency of the
government that taxes everyone.
Section 401(k) of the IRS Code
defined circumstances in which
money held in trusts for others
might not be taxable.
In 1981, for the first time,
a company invoked this clause
to ask that the defined
contribution plan that they were
setting up would not be taxed.
Well actually,
to make it clear,
what it would be is if the
employer or employee made
contributions to the plan,
then there would be no
tax--that would be a tax
deduction for the amount of the
contribution until later--after
the person retires.
It would be taxed many years
later as ordinary income when
they received it.
By postponing the tax,
it was a significant tax
advantage.
After 1981, there was a
tremendous revolution in our
tax--in our pension system
because it led--first of all,
people liked tax breaks and it
sounds good to get a tax break.
But secondly,
people start--unions were
declining.
Unions, which had always
advocated defined benefits,
were declining as a force in
the U.S.
and people were developing in
the United States more of an
investment culture.
They liked the idea that they
would have a defined
contribution plan where there
would be a portfolio,
which is theirs,
which is being invested for
their retirement,
rather than trust the company
to provide a benefit in
retirement.
The general public showed a
strong preference for defined
contribution plans after 1981
and so that is a big force.
The U.S.
was a leader in defined
contribution plans,
but it is now spreading all
over the world.
I think it again reflects the
change in our world culture.
So, they're growing in Europe
and other--I guess
Mexico's--Chile--so many of the
pension plans now are of the
defined contribution
variety--even government pension
plans.
The government social security
plan in Chile invests for you
and there's a portfolio and you
can get on a website,
I understand.
I've never done it in Chile,
but you can see what the
balance is in your account.
Another thing that defined
contribution plans began to do
with the advent of 401(k) is
they would allow you,
as an employee or as the
pensioner, to choose the general
categories of investments.
That would typically--in a
defined contribution plan after
1981, there would be a number of
mutual funds that you could
invest your pension money in.
Though you couldn't take it out
until you retired,
you could choose which,
from a selected list of mutual
funds, you could invest your
money in.
This helped promote mutual
funds dramatically and it also
created more of an investment
culture in our society.
That's where we are now.
The defined benefit pension
plan is declining rapidly;
ERISA is still not irrelevant
because they're still important,
but ERISA is becoming less and
less important.
We're moving on toward a
country--when you get your first
job, the first thing you will
get, I can predict,
will be a 401(k) plan;
you will probably not be given
a defined benefit pension.